and I think might be a good thing for
you to write a little letter to those
children
may you let them know
you sorry
that they're not going to have anyone
left you know
I mean just say something and tell them
how you personally think your uncle
maybe he got it wrong this time because
it's wrong
that they lost actor Wendell Pierce may
be best known for his score of roles on
TV and in film including the HBO hit the
wire which Rolling Stone named the
fourth best TV show of all time but over
the course of his nearly 40-year career
the Juilliard train performer has always
maintained a presence on stage Fresh Off
rave reviews and an Olivier award
nomination on London's West End Pierce
is back on Broadway with Death of a
Salesman in a classic American role he's
now making all his own
this is great I mean it's a it's an
honor for the first time in his career
you're not just on Broadway you are
front and
getting the Star Treatment on the great
white way I'm in a small fraternity of
men who played the role on Broadway and
if anything falls off his desk while
you're talking to him like a package or
something like that don't you pick it up
they got office boys for that he's also
the first black man to play the lead in
Death of a Salesman it heightens all the
themes of the play without having to
change a thing it adds to it the
variables that that magnifies what was
happening for African Americans at that
time set in the late 1940s Arthur
Miller's tragedy tells the story of
salesman Willie Lowman and the death of
his American dream it shows you the
psychological impact of discrimination
and at the same time
it was always there in the play that's
yes and the things that are the
variables that caused it but 34
and it's not a piece of fruit pursuing
an illusion of a dream or something that
you desire and understanding that
there's a wealth that you have and love
and family
that if you put blinders on you can lose
sight of
the play Stars Tony Award winner Andre
de Shields is lowman's mysterious
brother Ben and Sharon D Clark as
Willy's wife Linda he's not to be
allowed to fall into his grave like like
an old dog attention
attention must be finally paid to such a
person it's been a whirlwind beginning
in 2019 when Pierce signed up for the
London Revival fresh off his run in
Canada on suits do you know why I love
that picture playing the father of
Meghan Markle because I'm still your
little girl he was also shooting
Amazon's Jack Ryan in Bogota Colombia
and traveling to promote other projects
around the globe yeah afraid so but he's
most famous for roles on two HBO series
we need to bring in the lieutenant one
is the wires detective bunk Moreland
the other is trombone player Antoine
Baptiste on Tremec set in his hometown
of New Orleans well we tried to do which
of May is to peel back the curtain
of disillusionment and show you all the
things that were already there
conditions of poverty and conditions of
structural deterioration but then also
the beauty of it which is our culture
and how we can mine that as a way to
restore not only the city physically but
restore our spirit
filming for the show began five years
after Hurricane Katrina
precious time spent with his dying
mother as he fought to restore his old
neighborhood up Pontchartrain Park
Brick by Brick House by house block by
block we rebuilt it and here we are
almost 20 years later we have restored
it and it is now on the national
register of historic places this is it
you're on stage three hours first of all
to bring an American classic to Broadway
still working yes as you can see in the
36 37 years since when
Broadway in 1985
. he's seen a world of change and he's
embracing it finally we're getting a
perspective that was not allowed to be
voiced before we're giving that chance
casting a shadow
there's a greatness in you Biff
remember that and given that unsung
heart song all kinds of greatness that
is felt by so many people so many
generations of people
that we're now giving voice to
there was personality in it Howard there
was respect all of that has led to what
he calls the role of a lifetime one of
deep reflection you start to think of
your own inadequacies on my best days
behind me where have I failed where have
I missed the opportunities to love and
create family it's a real time of
self-reflection
and what have you come up with
there are many disappointments in life
but you have control over it with the
decisions you make and even when you
have taken missteps
there is always
time for Redemption
that voice yeah I'm thinking about that
it was fun yeah you know I asked him
because he was in a deeply reflective
mood I asked him you know five years
from now what does your life look like
he says King Lear he said and a wife
with children so he was really thinking
him he's never been married before uh
back to the point Death of a Salesman
debuts tomorrow at the Hudson theater so
I know it's already getting a lot of
Acclaim and uh I'm going so
he is such a varied back the roles like
when you were going through some of them
like oh yeah I forgot and I forgot he's
one of those uh you know character
actors who people don't know his name
but they definitely know him they know
his voice too and the third season is
Jack Ryan coming oh can't wait